tell me his name again vanna's he's a
plague Tony he invades planets he takes
what he wants he wipes out half the
population
he said Loki the attack on New York
that's him what a journey of discovery
with that banner character I mean he's a
he's a really interesting character as a
jekyll-and-hyde character there are two
beings that are battling over control of
the host body that's unique story it
sets him apart from anywhere else in the
universe because of that me and these
two beings hate each other and and don't
like helping each other and we thought
it would be more interesting to explore
banner as a hero the banner is someone
who whines to get you know help from his
alter ego who he dislikes so we thought
it would be more interesting choice to
take him down a path where the Hulk is
not interested in helping him anymore
that these two have reached an impasse
with each other and and banner has to
rise to the occasion I think people have
interpreted that hope scared I mean
certainly that's not a I don't know that
the Hulk ever he's had his ass kicked
before you know but and he loves a good
fight but I think that it's really
reflective of the journey from Ragnarok
is that these two characters you know
are constantly in conflict with each
other over control right and and I think
if the Hulk or to say why it's like you
know the banner banner only wants Hulk
for fighting you know what's I think
he's he's had enough of saving banners
ass I think sometimes you see the
disconnect that your tie that you're
referencing with toys or or trailers or
whatever the case may be because you
know the the the work on those has to
start so early in the process that it
kind of pre predates where we arrive the
scriptures you know even him maybe
things that we're talking about the
outline phase from a year prior to the
movie hey everybody it's Charlie this is
gonna be my hope video for Infinity Ward
definitively answering per the directors
what was going on with his character so
if you're finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the
Marvel videos I'm also still doing the
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway we'll keep
doing that till the blu-ray drops and
then that's what the giveaway will be
for I'll explain that at the end of the
video but since the weekend
Finity war came out the biggest theory
that I've seen on all the infinity war
videos that I posted about what was
going on with the hole was that most
people think that he had some crazy form
of PTSD because he got his ass handed to
him so bad by thanos but per the Russos
they say that that's actually not what
they were going for the way they explain
it it's all about banner versus Hulk
like I should even call this video the
Hulk vs. banner in infinity war like the
biggest battle of that banner fights
isn't with those outriders when he's in
the Hulk Buster is actually with the
Hulk inside of him so if you didn't
catch it they also reference a scene
from Thor Ragnarok because they say this
is a through-line that started during
Ragnarok although you could say that it
started when the Hulk started it's
always been a struggle between those two
characters it's just that Ragnarok
really called it out in a very specific
way which personality wins out and what
is their relationship like so the scene
the Russos are specifically talking
about is the scene where Thor is trying
to get Banner to come help him take down
hella and he's like you don't want me
you just want the Hulk but this time
it's like he had the keys in the car and
I was locked in the trunk
no it's not what matters what I'm trying
to tell you is that that if I turn it to
the Hulk again Banner may never come
back I just told you if I turn into the
Hulk I am never gonna come back again
and you don't care the Russos are saying
that during infinity war the
through-line that they're picking up on
is the idea that the Hulk feels like
banner only wants him when he's time for
a fight so it has this whole new
dimension to the Hulk's character
because you really don't think about him
so much as a character as you think
about him as an extension of banner like
banner needs to help out or he's in
danger he hooks out smashes things then
the Sun gets real low and somebody calls
him down and he goes back to being
banner again but if your big comic book
reader then you know that they are two
distinct personality
one wins out over the other but there
have been various points in the comics
where they've separated those two
characters where like somehow banner
himself becomes separated from the Hulk
so you have them both occupying the
physical universe for a period and a lot
of people have wondered about Avengers 4
and what the future of the hook is I
will totally do a video about that there
are a number of directions they could
take the character even if Mark Ruffalo
doesn't want to continue playing the
Hulk after Avengers 4 there were a
couple times though when banner tried to
force the Hulk out and couldn't do it
there at least three separate times you
have the first time when he's standing
on the street Antonis like you're
embarrassing me in front of The Wizard
then just a couple moments later when
he's slapping his face in the park so he
can try and rejoin the fight then later
in that cool obsidian fight when he
screams no and doesn't want to come out
now we know it doesn't necessarily have
anything to do with his relative fear or
feelings about Thanos
it's just his temporary hatred of Banner
The Hulk really doesn't like banner and
banner doesn't really like the Hulk it
wasn't exactly where I was expecting
them to take that relationship but it
does make a lot of sense if banner
himself was feeling that same thing from
Thor ah you don't want me you just want
the Hulk you just want that big green
monster to fight for you but hopefully
that clears up any PTSD theories so you
can wipe those aside Hulk himself is
fine he's not afraid of Thanos he's more
pissed off for banner and it's this
fight for dominance between the two of
them remember during Ragnarok how Banner
was like if I change back into the Hulk
I won't be able to change back but come
to find out the beginning of infinity
war boom he's right back to being Banner
you know it's the other way around he
can't change back into the Hulk I think
come to find he will change back into
the hope during Avengers 4 but they said
the reason they included that trailer
shot of the Hulk which was totally fake
nowhere in the film were they running in
the forest here together like this they
never intended there to be any actual
Hulk in Wakanda
there was a toy that was released by
Funko awhile ago with the hook busting
out of the Hulkbuster armor that was
also never anything that was in the
movie that's not a deleted scene or
anything like that there's just
something that they did to sell toys
they always intended for banner to be
the one to have to solve his own
problems during infinity war after that
first big scene with Thanos so going
into Avengers 4 the whole idea is that
banner in The Hulk now
need to come to terms so that they can
work together and be the whole cast hook
that they could possibly be it's a
really hilarious idea but you're never
gonna get a hundred percent of what the
Hulk is capable of if they're both
fighting each other when they work
together I think the idea is is they
could be the ultimate version of the
whole people talk about world breaker
Hulk now that's a very different type of
character from the comics but what I'll
do is I'll do an Avengers four or Hulk
videos sometime in the near future I've
gotten a lot of requests for character
videos like Scarlet Witch and vision
what's gonna happen to them are they
gonna come back into the MCU will vision
stay dead so if there are any other
specific character videos that you want
me to do just let me know in the
comments like even Sebastian Stan was
doing more interviews talking about what
his version of Captain America would be
like he basically said that it would be
the darkest version ever so just leave
all your requests in the comments below
there are a lot of you that want me to
do a red skull video that's kind of
spoilery so I'm just waiting a couple
more days to get people more chances to
see the film because they're just like
one or two things that are still super
spoilery but I'll say congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner Obie calzone
please private message me so I can get
your contact details there'll be a new
round when I post new Marvel that should
be tomorrow there's a bunch of Deadpool
that I'm trying to get through too so
I'll try to post that as fast as
possible but click here for my soulstone
video the Russos also just confirmed
everything about this and the soul world
and click here to rewatch that thor
Stormbreaker scene thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]